Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wir stehen vor dem Salon und es beginnt schon zu winden. Es ist aber noch kein Herbst, sondern es ist Sommeranfang, es ist alles durcheinander.
Wie wird das Wetter wohl auf Sylt werden? Da findet ja die Hochzeit statt. Und du weißt, wer dort auch eine Rede halten wird?
Ich hab nur ein bisschen gehört, wer da ist. Habe oder eingeladen, weiß nicht, ob er kommt. Scholz ist natürlich da. Und eine Rede wird vielleicht Sloterdijk halten, das finde ich gut.
Sehr richtig. Ja. Das ist natürlich auch schlimm, wenn man als Philosoph in diese Tiefen hinabsteigt.
Ach du großer Gott. Was will er denn sagen da?
Vielleicht wiederholt er einfach noch mal seinen Essay von der gebenden und der nebenden Hand und dann bekommt Lindner noch mal gesagt, dass alles richtig ist, was er jetzt gerade tut.
Genau, es geht ja um die Eheschließung von Christian Lindner. Vielleicht liest er auch aus Zorn und Zeit.
Ach so.
Ist ja für ihn auch nicht ganz falsch. Die einen machen das Gelübde auf ewig und so und dann kommt er mit Zorn und Zeit. Wir sind ja, meine Damen und Herren. Wer weiß. Wir wünschen allen alles Gute, die es gebrauchen können und allen anderen viel Spaß auf so Happenings. Ich habe gesehen, auf Twitter kursieren schon die besten 9 Euro Zugverbindungen nach Süd.
Ja, das vielleicht mal die Hochzeit-Crashen ist vielleicht, ja man wird es lesen, wenn es stattfindet. Im Zug jedenfalls ist es mitunter sehr voll und dann ist es wieder sehr leer. Es ist sehr eigenartig, war jetzt auch wieder recht viel unterwegs und sehe aber auch, dass viele junge Leute offenbar von diesem Ticket Gebrauch machen. Also das ist ganz, ganz deutlich zu sehen und das hört man dann an so Gesprächen mit. Es sind einfach Leute, die jetzt so ein bisschen Deutschland kennenlernen, die Freunde besuchen, die also nur sinnvolles Hits mit diesem Ticket tun. Und dann hört man aber doch so viele Ältere, die sich irgendwie aufregen darüber. Und das ist schon ganz, ganz eigenartig, wie das dann sich immer noch so durchdrückt. Und was mir aufgefallen ist, es gibt ja ein neues Twitter-Genre. Und zwar, man setzt seine Follower darüber in Kenntnis, wie der jeweilige Zugführer mit Menschen umgeht im Zug, die keine Maske tragen. Das ist ein neues Genre.
Ist das so neu? Ich dachte, das gab es schon mal, als ich bin hier draußen im Park, mache ein Foto und zeige...
Genau, das gibt es natürlich. Ja, das kennen wir natürlich. Oder wir schicken mal die Drohnen los und zeigen dann, da sind Menschen in Parks. Aber jetzt wird noch mal so ganz klar Wert auf die Züge gelegt, denn das ist ja so mit der letzte Ort, wo überhaupt noch die Maskenpflicht ist. Und ich habe dann den Tweet einer Journalistin, die ich jetzt nicht beim Namen nennen will, weil es mir jetzt nicht darum geht, Einzelne hier vorzuführen, obwohl ich große Lust daran hätte, habe ich einen Tweet gelesen, die dann sagt, toller Zugführer, so sinngemäß. Er hat schon angekündigt, jeder, der die Maske nicht trägt, fliegt sofort raus, denn wir brauchen Platz im Zug. Und das ist mein Zugführer. Und da finde ich erst mal interessant, dass es ja doch diesen autoritären Charakter der Deutschen gibt, dass man wirklich sagt, toll, dass da jetzt hier der Mann durchgreift. Das sind aber auch, also selbe Journalistin würde immer sagen, wie schlimm das alles so autoritär wird. Und dann habe ich mir einfach angeguckt, wo fährt jene Journalistin hin? Und sie fuhr zum Christopher Street Day nach Köln. Nun war ich am Sonntag in Köln, weil ich da eine Moderation der Philharmonie hatte und bin also auch ein bisschen da hineingeraten. Eine Million Menschen kommen dann nach Köln. Und man hat so Teile des Zuges sind dann da so vorbeispaziert. Und ich sag's mal so, die einzige Maske, die ich gesehen habe, war so eine Hundemaske, die jemand da auf hatte. Und sonst war da Ringelpiez mit Anfassen. Und das finde ich dann doch interessant, dass man einfach sagt, ah ja, die Sphäre der Bahn, da will ich jetzt, dass noch mal hart durchgegriffen wird. Und dann steige ich aber aus in Köln, wo eine Million Menschen sich in den Armen liegen. Und das ist dieser, ich will so sagen, ich kann es nicht ertragen, wenn es nicht logisch ist. Da habe ich wirklich ein Problem mit, wenn man nicht logisch bleibt. Also wenn man sagt, okay, ich will mich jetzt für immer vor Corona schützen, dann bedeutet das in meinen Augen, ich muss immer Maske tragen in allen geschlossenen Räumen oder wo Menschen sich auf Plätzen eng zusammen befinden. Dann darf ich auch wirklich jetzt hier ganz klar verkünden, ich gehe nie mehr in ein Restaurant, nie mehr in eine Bar, denn da kann ich ja nicht mit Maske sitzen. Wenn man dazu bereit ist, und ich glaube, es sind ganz, ganz wenige, die es machen würden, dann kann man das tun. Aber dann werde ich, hab das jetzt auch so ein paar Nachrichten bekommen nach meinen Corona-Aussagen, darauf hingewiesen, ja, was gibt Long-Covid? Ja, das gibt es. Und da haben wir jetzt auch immer mehr Erkenntnisse. Aber das Tragen von Masken punktuell, das verzögert ja, dass man sich infiziert, weil die statistische Wahrscheinlichkeit etwas damit reduziert wird. Aber es ist ja ein logischer Fehler zu glauben, dass das Virus dadurch verschwindet, oder dass man durch die Verzögerung, die die Infektion ganz verhindert. Sondern man sagt dann, also klar, wenn ich jetzt punktuell Maske trage, dann kann es gut sein, dass ich es mir nicht heute hole, sondern nächste Woche. Dann gibt es auch dieses andere Argument der Intensivbettenüberlastung. Das stellt sich aber jetzt gerade gar nicht, weil die nicht überlastet sind zurzeit.
Ja, es haben ja sehr viele Grad Corona. Ich stelle aber fest, locker, also machen, sind verpflichtet, Corona-Ferien zu machen, Hänger zu Hause rum, verbringen die Zeit, bis sie wieder raus dürfen, Freitesten geht ja heute relativ früh. Leider sind dann die anderen des Haushalts immer gerade dann dran, wenn man selber sich grad weigetestet hat und so. Aber das Prinzip, was du jetzt grad beschrieben hast, ist ja vielleicht und man hört schon an unserer Themenwahl hier. Es sind grad sehr, nicht unaufregende, aber wenig zu kommentierende Ereignisse. Wir sind keine Engländer, da ist grad Rambazamba und Zirkus. Da gäbe es mehr zu sagen. Aber das Prinzip finde ich ganz interessant, im Zug zu sitzen, sich darüber aufzuregen, dass Leute keine Maske tragen und dann in Köln beim Christopher-Study-Day auszusteigen und drei Tage durchzufeiern. Oder einen Tag. Und es gibt ja diesen Begriff der Compliance, der übersetzt bedeutet Therapietreue. Und Therapietreue meint natürlich im Medizinischen, es wird ja so zweigleisig zum einen die wirklich medikamentöse Therapie. Da hält man sich am besten dran. Also da ist man dem Arzt sozusagen ausgeliefert, aber auch seinem Körper. Und dann gibt es ja die psychologische Seite, die ist ein bisschen psychosomatisch. Und das ist ja bei Long-Covid auch ein großes Problem. Es korreliert ja sehr mit grundsätzlichen Gemütszuständen. Also Long-Covid kommt bei den Leuten vor, die sagen wir mal grundsätzlich eh schon anfällig waren für Depressionen. Das klingt von mir jetzt wieder so locker dahergesagt, aber es sind die Mittelalten, am Schreibtisch versauernden, Burnout-geplagten, weil überlastet, aber inhaltlich unterforderten Menschen, die dann auch besonders häufig Long-Covid...
Oder Leute mit Herzproblemen, die nicht erkannt wurden bislang. Also wo sich sowas dann, das ist dann einfach auch ja schlimm. Genau. Und da ist es dann, und das trifft einen ja natürlich so ganz unvermittelt. Also da hat man nicht schon, ach, ich hab da so eine Disposition vielleicht, da muss ich vorsichtig, sondern es trifft einen dann. Aber ich glaube, dass auch da... Also das erwarte ich jetzt eigentlich von dem Gesundheitsminister, nicht immer nur zu loben, wir haben da eine tolle neue Studie zu Long-Covid, sondern da würde ich jetzt gerne konkrete Maßnahmen, dass diese Leute eine richtig gute Betreuung bekommen, damit die da wieder rauskommen, damit nicht noch ein Päckchen weiterzutragen ist. Weil wie du sagst, da viele schon sind, die ohnehin schon mit psychischen Problemen zu kämpfen haben.
Genau und da braucht man, also da hat der Begriff Therapietreue so besondere Dimensionen, sondern wenn man zum Arzt geht und man stellt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Hitzeerschöpfung ist ja zum Beispiel jetzt im ICD-10 steht es ja drin, also es kann als Diagnose gestellt werden. Man kann durchaus mal zum Arzt gehen und sagen, es ist einfach zu heiß, kann hier eine Krankschreibung. Und dann kann es durchaus sein, dass man wegen Hitzeerschöpfung zum Arzt geht und der Arzt dann zu einem sagt, sie sind ja gar nicht nur hitzeerschöpft, sondern sie sind ja hitzeerschöpft, weil sie auch schon andere Krankheiten, die bei uns auch im Katalog stehen, so wie du es eben schon sagtest, schlummerten und dann plötzlich sind sie diagnostiziert und offenbar. Also die sogenannte Multimorbidität oder wie auch immer das dann im Fachjargon heißt. So und psychisch ist ja so diese Therapietreue bei psychischen Behandlungen. Und Long Covid ist ja dadurch, dass es so diese Schwächung und so, es schlägt sich auch aufs Gemüt nieder, Long Covid zu haben, wie auch Long Lockdown. Ist ja auch ein Problem, das zu behandeln ist. So und da gehört ja bei Therapietreue dazu, dass man die Therapie irgendwann als seine eigene Aufgabe übernimmt. Also abseits des Therapeuten, der natürlich dann irgendwann nur unterstützend, am Anfang viele Ratschläge vielleicht, aber irgendwann dreht sich es ja um auf Unterstützung, Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe. So, also irgendwann muss man ja den Sinn der Therapie und die Ziele als die wirklich eigenen anerkennen und ist nicht einfach irgendein Medikament ausgeliefert. Und da zurückgekoppelt auf die Erlebnisse im Zug, irgendwann im Zug muss man ja die eigene Entscheidung treffen, nicht ob man jetzt gegen die Regeln die Maske ablässt, sondern ob man vielleicht Akzeptanz dafür findet, dass Menschen, die wie man selber nachdem man aus dem Zug ausgestiegen ist, ihre Maske absetzen, das auch schon im Zug machen, ohne dass man das gleich wieder zum Anlass nimmt, nur nach den Regeln sich darüber aufzuregen, weil die Regeln halt so sind. Oder eben auch die individuellen und nachvollziehbaren Gründe, die man dann hat, eine Maske abzusetzen, wie zum Beispiel man sitzt allein im 6. Abteil, muss man da vorbeigehen und sagen, aber die Regeln sind andere. Nee, man kann auch die Situation, das Eigenrecht der Situation einfach gewähren lassen und feststellen, fände ich für mich auch nicht schlecht, jetzt einen 6. Abteil zu haben, weil dann könnte ich ja meine Maske abziehen, ohne jemanden zu gefährden.
Gestern fuhr ich von Frankfurt mit so einer Regionalbahn nach Koblenz, und da steigen dann ja sehr viele Schüler ein, 15- 16-Jährige und ja, natürlich haben da viele die Maske einfach nicht mehr auf. Ich habe hier die Maske einfach nur auf, um keine Diskussionen zu haben. Das ist einfach für mich komfortabler. Und dann sind da Frauen um die 60, die sich dann unglaublich empören darüber, dass die jungen Menschen jetzt da keine Maske anhaben. Und das finde ich einfach falsch. Diese jungen Menschen haben keine große Gefahr dadurch. Die Damen, wenn sie sich so eingeschränkt fühlen, dann können sie eine richtig gute FFP2-Maske tragen.
Selbstständigkeit ist da nämlich gegeben.
Und wenn ich mir die Bemerkungen erlauben darf, ich glaube, es wäre auch ganz gut, wenn die sonst mal auf ihre Gesundheit noch achten würden. Und ich will jetzt eine, ich weiß, das ist ganz böse, was ich jetzt sage, aber ich will es trotzdem mal ansprechen. Also ich bin ja dafür, dass jeder so leben soll, wie er will. Und das tue ich ja auch, denn ich rauche ja zum Beispiel. Und man weiß, rauchen verkürzt das Leben und ist schlecht. Das ist vollkommen klar. Ich telefonierte mit einem Soziologen. Ich sage den Namen nicht. Ich mag ihn auch sehr. Ich hoffe, er hört nicht zu. Aber andererseits muss man auch wissen, wenn man mit mir spricht, alles kann Material werden. Und dieser Soziologe sagte zu mir, ja, ich will Corona nicht nochmal bekommen. Ist natürlich auch dreifach geimpft und so. Ist deshalb noch immer für Maskenpflicht und würde auch für mehr Maskenpflicht plädieren. Geht aber auch in Restaurants. Also da ist schon wieder so dieser komische Ding, dass man inkonsequent ist. Und sagt dann zu mir, also ein Soziologe, ein Mensch, der Experte für Gesellschaft ist, sagt dann zu mir, weißt du, Wolfgang, ich hab ja Übergewicht und ich will mir auch das Rauchen nicht abgewöhnen. Und das war die Begründung. Und ich habe in dem Moment nicht richtig reagiert, habe nun gesagt, ah ja, und dachte, was hat er jetzt eigentlich gerade gesagt? Dann anschließend, er sagte, ich will mich nicht einschränken. Ich möchte gerne rauchen und ich möchte gerne viel essen. Und ich finde das vollkommen okay, wenn jemand viel essen will und rauchen will. Aber ich kann ja nicht sagen, ich will mich nicht einschränken, aber ich möchte gerne, dass sich alle anderen für mich einschränken. Und da muss man einfach sagen, man hat eine Selbstverantwortung dann auch für sich. Ich habe eine gute Freundin, die, und sie wäre mir nicht böse, wenn ich das sage, die ziemlich korpulent ist. Und sie sagte einfach mal zu mir, Wolfgang, ich koche, backe und esse so unglaublich gern, dass mir das wert ist. Das ist für sie wichtiger. Und dann finde ich das absolut in Ordnung. Nur kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, ich rauche. Und deswegen bin ich vielleicht ein bisschen anfälliger dann, wenn ich Covid bekomme, dass das dann bei mir nicht so milder verlaufen wird. Und deswegen strengt ihr euch mal bitte alle ein. Das kann ich nicht erwarten. Und ich würde nochmal, also was mich aber wirklich mürbel macht, ist diese Inkonsequenz. Mein Vater erzählte mir, hat eine Bekannte getroffen, bei Edeka, die da ohne Maske stand und dann aber sagte, sie findet das gut, wenn die Maskenpflicht bleibt. Dann fragte er sie aber, wie kann das sein? Du trägst jetzt hier keine Maske. Und dann sagte sie, hier fühle ich mich sicher. Und das würde man, und da merkt man aber auch selbst, wenn die Leute dann doch ins Restaurant gehen und doch das eine oder andere machen. In gewisser Weise haben sie dieses Leben mit dem Virus akzeptiert, können aber nicht diesen letzten Schritt gehen. Ich will einen Vergleich machen, der auch nicht ein direkter Vergleich ist, um einfach eine Argumentation zu veranschaulichen. Wenn man sich beispielsweise vor AIDS schützen will, würde man nicht punktuell sich schützen. Man würde nicht sagen, ja, aber sonntags verwende ich grundsätzlich keine Kondome oder so. Das würde man nicht sagen, da würde auch jeder sagen, bist du irgendwie verrückt, also entweder oder. Und genauso sehe ich das auch bei den Masken. Man kann nicht sagen, ich gehe jetzt eben ins Restaurant, aber gleich wenn ich in den Bus steige nicht. Und deswegen finde ich einfach diese Inkonsequenz so doof und finde es vor allem schlimm, dass man jetzt jungen Leuten nochmal da einreden will, was sie alles tun sollen. Und diese Selbstbeschneidung findet dann bei den jungen Leuten auch so statt, weil sie eine gewisse Angst haben, dass sie dann irgendwas Schlimmes tun. Und ich finde jetzt einfach muss es von der Politik ganz klar das Signal geben, dass Menschen nicht mehr, also gerade Menschen unter 60, sich nicht mehr einschränken müssen, auch im Winter nicht, wenn der Verlauf weiter so bleibt, wenn jetzt nicht irgendeine Horrorvariante auftritt. Aber dann muss das auch einfach gewährleistet sein, dass der 20-Jährige und 30-Jährige und 40-Jährige sagen kann, ich möchte gerne in dieses Konzert. Ja, ich weiß, da kommen tausend Leute. Kann sein, dass ich da auch mal Corona bekomme, aber das Risiko gehe ich jetzt ein.
Genau. Und ihr hört schon, uns geht es nur um unsere Veranstaltung im Dezember. Und ja, wir wollen unser unbeschwertes Leben, unser, wie soll man sagen, sich geistig einfach treiben lassen zurück. Da sind wir nicht der Einzigen, denn ich hatte dir schon angekündigt, ich will noch über einen Tweet sprechen. Und der passt vielleicht auch, weil wir schon über Christian Lindner sprachen. Vielleicht belassen wir es einfach, ihn vorzulesen. In diesen unbekümmerten Sommerzeiten kann man ja durchaus mal wie folgt twittern und danach sagen wir, wer es geschrieben hat. Was kann ich wissen? Was kann ich tun? Kann es grundsätzliche Fragen? Also, wie ich es darauf finde, das sind ganz grundsätzliche Fragen. Was kann ich wissen? Was kann ich tun? Die politisch Verantwortlichen könnten mehr wissen. Hätten sie etwas getan? So steht die Corona Politik nur vor den Scherben unterlassener Willensleistung. Und dass ein Tweet von Dagmar Rosenfeld um einen ihrer eigenen Texte über die Evaluierungs Bemühungen in Deutschland, was Corona angeht. Und das finde ich, wir fahren in Deutschland ganz wunderbar zweigleisig, dass wir auf der einen Seite mit Christian Drosten und so weiter die Koryphäen dieses Forschungsgebietes in Deutschland haben. Politisch aber ein Regelwerk, das Tovu Wabohu oder wie man das nennt, ist flankiert von einem Mindset in der Bevölkerung, das auch nicht auf der Höhe der Zeit ist, sondern wie du eben schon ein paar Sachen herausgestellt hast, so punktuell davor geht, überhaupt keine Ziele so richtig formuliert, sondern alle bringen so ihren Individualistischen. Also ich will meine Freiheit haben, ich will aber das andere mich beschützen, ich will mich beschützen und am liebsten sogar noch vor mir selbst und so weiter, deswegen verlasse ich gar nicht mehr das Haus. Wir sind noch überhaupt nicht dazu gekommen, das ganze Maskenthema auch mal unter Selbstschutz zu thematisieren. Das läuft immer noch unter, damit schützen wir die anderen. Nein, man kann sich heute auch sehr gut selber schützen mit Masken. Auch noch kein Thema. Es ist ein wirkliches großes Durcheinander. Aber wie gesagt...
Was wollte uns dann jetzt Dagmar Rosen, die Ex-Frau von Christian Lindner, eigentlich uns da sagen?
Sie wollte uns fragen, ob wir auch finden, dass die grundsätzlichen Fragen, die Kant schon aufgeworfen hat, im Raume stehen und ob am Ende einfach nur Willensleistung fehlt und ob es eine unterlassene, und ich war, wir reden von, also unterlassene Hilfeleistung, da macht sie unterlassene Willensleistung draus. Und ich finde das irgendwie so grotesker. Ist überhaupt so anzubieten als Stefan, als Stefan Akteur.
Aber wie würde es dann nochmal konkret, also wurde nicht genügend Maßnahmen betrieben, hat man nicht, oder geht es nur um die Evaluierung, hat man nicht genügend Daten gesammelt und diese ausgewertet, hat man nicht evidenzbasiert genug gearbeitet. Zumal es ja noch die zwei anderen Fragen, die Kant schon gibt, nämlich was darf ich hoffen und wir hoffen darauf, dass wir einen Winter mit vielen Veranstaltungen haben, damit wir damit dann auch die vierte kantische Frage beantworten können, nämlich was ist der Mensch und das würde ich sagen, können wir gleich dann sagen, das ist nämlich dann ein Gesellschaftswesen, das sich mitunter auch gerne mal trifft, zum Beispiel zu einer Podcastveranstaltung.
Es gibt ja noch die fünfte Kantfrage von Georg Simmel, was sagt uns Kant? Fragezeichen. Und vielleicht steckt hier so eine kleine Paradoxie steckt er drin, denn Dagmar Rosenfeld weiß ja drauf hin, die Politik weiß nichts, kann also nicht handeln, hätte aber handeln müssen, um jetzt etwas zu wissen. Und gut, ok, zugestandenermaßen, das stimmt irgendwie, aber das hätte man als Tweet belassen können, da muss man dann keinen auf den Text verweisen. Sondern dann stellt man einfach wirklich nur 2022 fest, Leute, Corona ist da und ja, Corona ist da.
Genau und ich kenne sehr viele Leute, die sich sehr, sehr geschützt haben und dies dann jetzt bekommen haben, das auch mitunter gar nicht so genau wissen. Also wir müssen eine gewisse Gelassenheit da reinbringen und uns um die besonders kümmern und das ist auch der politische Auftrag, die es hart trifft. Also von Corona plötzlich überrascht werden, hart getroffen werden und dann muss man vielleicht im Winter noch mal darüber nachdenken, wie man gezielt Leute, die zu Risikogruppen gehören bzw. die sehr alt sind, wie man die schützt und das darf aber nicht mehr dahin gehen, dass man junge Leute in irgendeiner Weise beschneidet und sonst sind die Risiken des Lebens, da bin ich auch überhaupt nicht auf einem neoliberalen oder biopolitischen Trip, dass ich jetzt, du bist ja manchmal, du würdest ja gerne Fitnessprogramme habe ich manchmal den Eindruck verordnen.
Diesen einen Punkt wollte ich gerade noch machen.
So Michelle Obama mäßig, ich bin da ja überhaupt nicht dafür, ich finde ja, ich bin ja eine rheinische Frohnatur und freue mich, wenn Leute Spaß am Essen haben oder gerne mal eine Zigarette rauchen oder gerne ein Gläschen Wein trinken, das finde ich alles in Ordnung und da würde ich sagen, da soll das jeder machen, klar, Maß halten in einer Weise, dass man sich nicht das Leben schwer macht durch die Genüsse, da muss man immer ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, das kenne ich natürlich auch selbst, wenn der Abend ein bisschen zu bunt wird, aber das muss dann jeder auch nochmal selbst für sich austarieren und manche haben da auch eine größere Robustheit als ich zum Beispiel, aber da würde ich immer sagen, jeder soll da machen, aber nicht so weit, dass man sagt und bitte beschränkt die anderen euch, weil ich mich nicht beschränken möchte oder kann.
Ja, dann lass mich noch diese kleine Anekdote aus meiner Woche erzählen, ich bin neuerdings, deswegen werde ich dich wahrscheinlich auch häufiger zu behälligen noch mit Sport als bisher schon, zweiter Vorsitzender eines kleinen Sportvereins und war in Funktion dessen auch beim Sportkreistag in Frankfurt. Stellst du dir vor wie ein politisches Plenum, bei dem der Sport ist ja auch föderal organisiert, also Landessportbünde, der Deutsche Olympische Sportbund und dann eben diese Sportkreise und so weiter. Und da gab es neben allen außerordentlichen Programmpunkten, die da so abgeliefert werden, eine sehr engagierte Plenumsrede unter verschiedenes von einem Tischtennisvereinschef, der auch noch mal darauf hinwies, Corona kam und die Vereine wurden stillgelegt. Und wer, wenn nicht die Sportvereine, kann wirklich was bei Long Covid und Long Lockdown und insbesondere auch Long Lockdown ausrichten. Wer hat denn die Möglichkeiten, Menschen, die immer nur gesagt bekommen, Reha vielleicht nächstes Jahr, Zuzahlung so und so, einfach ein Angebot zu machen mit such dir irgendeine Sportart aus. Du willst im Wasser aufrecht Fahrrad fahren? Das wird angeboten. Du willst im Stehen, weil die Beine schlapp machen, Tischtennis spielen? Wird angeboten. Du willst jungen Menschen begegnen und denen irgendwie was beibringen, weil du von früher noch was weißt, aber deine Bewegung beschränkt dich leider auf auf der Linie auf und ablaufen. Wer hat Übungsleiter? Also es gibt ganz viele Einfallstore, um solche Probleme wie Corona, die jetzt da waren, nicht nur nachzusorgen, sondern, das war ihm ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, auch auf die nächste Pandemie vorzubereiten mit körperlicher Ertüchtigung und so weiter, dass die Leute einfach Freundeskreise haben, Bewegungsabläufe haben, Routinen haben, um beispielsweise mit den nächsten Ansagen, jetzt müssen wir aber mal die und die Einschränkung, ah, dann weiß der Verein was zu tun ist, um die Leute trotzdem aktiv zu halten. Das wird über Vereine organisiert und das fand ich einen sehr wichtigen Punkt, deswegen haben wir dem auch allen mit Applaus gedankt, verhalten natürlich in so einer Runde, wird ins Protokoll aufgenommen und damit hat es sich. Aber ja, das ist natürlich auch eine politische Aufgabe, die Vereine mal finanziell so zu ertüchtigen, dass sie diese Angebote, die so viele Menschen einfach geben wollen, einfach geben können. Umso mehr Angebote man macht, umso mehr Leute rutschen dann da auch wieder in verantwortliche Rollen rein und können zurückgeben. Das sind alles so ganz langfristige Sozialisierungs- und Erfahrungsgeschichten, die da leider nicht ausreichend gefördert werden. Aber so habe ich es jetzt hier auch nochmal angemerkt und damit haben wir Corona für heute auch abgeschlossen, denn wir müssen, bevor wir gleich ganz insgeheim, nur für unsere Salonmitglieder über ein spektakulär gutes Buch reden, hier nochmal sagen, es ist wirklich ziemlich gut. Also die dunkle Seite der Christdemokratie-Geschichte, der autoritären Versuchungen, ich weiß nicht, wie du es fandest. Ich habe es wahnsinnig gerne gelesen.
Wir können da viel mit anfangen und können dieses Buch so als Grundlage jetzt für all diese Debatten, was passiert in der Union, was ist mit März, kann man immer wieder, glaube ich, darauf zurückgreifen und sagen, ja, da gibt es ja noch diese Linie und da gibt es noch diese Linie und diese muss man mal zusammenführen.
Genau, eine sehr gute, fast Lehrbuchartige Aufschlüsselung einer Heuristik, die uns sehr dazu dienen wird, uns künftig lustig zu machen über die CDU auch. Es ist ein ernstes Buch, aber...
Jaja, also das ist gar nicht, dass jetzt jemand denkt, das ist ein Spaßbuch und Zerführung der CDU oder sowas. Nein, nein, das ist schon ein sehr ernstes Buch, aber...
Für unser Anliegen, uns mit der CDU lustig zu machen, ist es sehr gut. Trotzdem. So, das ist sozusagen Teaser genug. Ich habe ansonsten einen Text über Tom Cruise, dachte ich, und mittendrin schlägt er plötzlich um und kommt auf deinen Kerbenschlag zu sprechen, nämlich wenn die größten Filmfinanciers der Welt potentiell, und dann nehme ich jetzt mal Amazon Prime Video, ein Drehbuch für Drehbücher schreibt, in dem, wie du so schön sagtest, in der Kulturzeit, verkannt wird, was Fiktion eigentlich ist. Nämlich nicht die Realität. Kommen wir da noch mal drauf zu sprechen. Was zeigt uns Tom Cruise eigentlich auf der Kino-Bühne? Wenn er meint, er muss das Flugzeug selber fliegen. Und dann kommt plötzlich Twin Peaks nochmal. Und da war ich doch ein bisschen überrascht. Du hast vielleicht diese neue dritte Staffel da schon gesehen. Ich nicht. Ich werde sie mir wahrscheinlich auch nicht angucken. Aber es gibt dann doch eine Szenerie, über die wir hier ganz dringend sprechen müssen. Außerdem reden wir über Russlands Kommunisten, die sich gerade mal wieder neu orientieren hinsichtlich, sind wir eigentlich für den Krieg und haben wir mit angezettelt oder sind wir gegen den Krieg und was? Denkt Putin eigentlich wirklich gerade über das Ende der UDSSR? Wir kennen ja die Story von Merkel, die sie uns gerade mal auf der Bühne erzählt hat. 2005, sie frisch im Amt, trifft Putin. Er bringt seine Hunde mit und dann stellen beide fest, für dich war der Mauerfall eine große Befreiung biografisch und für mich war es einfach der Untergang meiner Kultur. Und stellt sich raus, Putin denkt mittlerweile ganz anders darüber. Fand ich ein bisschen sehr überraschend, muss ich doch sagen. Und ja, Dol I angekündigt im letzten Podcast und außerdem ein aktivistischer Beitrag in der Zeit über Scholz Besuch in Afrika. Wir haben ihn ja sehr gelobt, ein Kanzler muss nach Afrika fahren und es gibt da auch echte Aufgaben zu erledigen. Und dann werden wir hier nochmal nachlesen, welcher Aufgabe sich Scholz da wirklich stellte in Afrika bei seiner jüngsten Reise. Und wir sind empört. Ich klammer dich da schon mal mit ein, ich bin empört.
Wie angekündigt der Essay Wir Zukunftslosen mit einigen interessanten Betrachtungen über Flucht und Flüchtlinge. Dann ein Roman über Kinderinfluencer in Frankreich. Die Kinder sind Könige. Das ist insofern bemerkenswert, als wir, glaube ich, noch gar nicht die Dimension verstanden haben von diesem System der Kinderarbeit, das da eigentlich entstanden ist. Ich habe auch Kritik an diesem Roman, aber es lohnt sich, darüber zu sprechen. Außerdem einen Artikel wie die Krypto-Szene versucht, mit Spenden den US-Wahlkampf natürlich mit zu beeinflussen. Dann ein Text von Branko Milanovic, der sich fragt, was, wenn Putin das erreicht, hat jetzt so langsam, was er erreichen will. Also der sagt, ja, das ist, erst mal sieht das aus, als wäre das nicht erfolgreich. Aber worum geht es ihm eigentlich? Und er ist ja ein Wirtschaftswissenschaftler, der sich mit Ungleichheit auseinandersetzt. Er sagt, aber es gibt da noch so ein anderes wichtiges Thema, was die Ungleichheit überdecken kann. Und das ist die Souveränität. Und das geht da mal durch, das ist sehr, sehr bemerkenswert. Und dann gibt es ja immer diesen State of Mobile Report. Und den gibt es auch dann noch mal so als Ausgabe über Food und Drink. Und zwar, wie man an den Mobilgeräten sich das Essen beschafft, zum Beispiel. Oder Rezepte und so weiter beschafft. Und da gibt es eine ganz interessante weltweite Erhebung dann über Daten. Und dann kann man dann auch mal sehen, welche Apps am meisten heruntergeladen sind. Das will ich auch vorstellen, das ist ganz bemerkenswert. Ja, das ist das Programm, das wir zu bieten haben im Salon. Wer also kommen will, kann das über Apple tun, kann das ganz traditionell über Steady tun. Und es gibt jetzt einen neuen Weg, den du uns aufgetan hast. Man kann es auch jetzt noch bequemer machen. Man muss bei Steady sein. Ich rede schon wieder. Wie geht es? Es geht auf jeden Fall über Spotify jetzt direkt da.
Yes, es ist wahnsinnig einfach und auch sehr leicht zu erklären. Ich will als Präampel mal kurz sagen, als ich die FAZ verließ, 2014, 15, war ja doch irgendwie die Stimmung so, diese Zeitungen sterben alle. Ich habe dieses Buch darüber geschrieben im Fernsehen, große Quälerei. Wir haben ja damals mit Junge Naiv diesen einen Piloten geschrieben. Das war auch so ein Ja, die Fernsehsender, sie wissen auch nicht so. Sie haben zwar noch große Budgets, aber die müssen auch immer heftiger intern gerechtfertigt werden. Wir sehen diese große Suchbewegung überall. Und jetzt sind wir hier so auf dieser freien Podcast Szene und stellen fest. Krass, ja, wir sind zwar auch irgendwie großen Konzernen ausgeliefert, die das Internet betreiben. Ohne die ginge es nicht. Aber es ist doch erstaunlich, wie uns YouTube Bandbreite in einem Ausmaß, wie wenn man sie privat finanziert, es würde viele tausend, tausend Euro kosten. Diese Videos einfach so mit einem Anbieter, wie man ihn als Privatfirma, wenn man irgendwas machen will, im Internet mit Daten und so weiter machen will. Apple stellt diese riesige Bibliografie, dieses Directory da bereit, um einfach das zu organisieren und so. Und Spotify, wir haben ja häufiger hier natürlich auch, Spotify ist halt auch wieder so ein Datensilo und so auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite. Wirklich bemerkenswert. Wir haben uns ja wirklich lustig gemacht, wie schwierig Apple sich immer noch tut, Podcast bezahlbar zu machen. Bei Spotify ist es jetzt so, die haben einfach sich die Landschaft angeschaut und haben gesehen, es gibt ja Anbieter wie Steady. Und die häufigste Frage, die wir bekommen, ist ja, kann ich den auch bei Spotify hören? Und dann sagen wir immer, ja, die Neuen Zwanziger kann man bei Spotify hören. Den Steady Feed leider nicht, weil das ist ein individueller Feed und so weiter und so fort. Mittlerweile ist es so, auch der Steady Feed ist bei Spotify abrufbar mit einem kleinen Schlüsselsymbol. Und wenn man aber Steady Kunde ist, klickt man da einfach drauf, sagt Spotify, hallo, ich bin der Kunde von Steady. Zack, kann man hören. Also man muss nicht bei Spotify plötzlich anfangen zu bezahlen oder sonst irgendwie, sondern man ist schon Steady Kunde oder kann dann einer werden und nutzt dann trotzdem weiter einfach Spotify, indem man Spotify durch einen Klick kurz sagt, ich bin übrigens ein legitimer Steady Kunde für dieses Angebot, gib mir den Feed und zack hat man in seinem offenbar immer noch sehr beliebten und zunehmend beliebten Spotify-Player dann auch den bezahlpflichtigen Inhalt, wie zum Beispiel Die Neuen Zwanziger. Ich finde das insgesamt eine gute Entwicklung. Denke mir auch irgendwie, wir haben in dem Feed auch Kapitelmarken, die zeigt Spotify auch nicht. Das ist natürlich für den Salon besonders schade, weil das sind einfach zehn Texte. Da kann man dann bequem einfach überspringen. Das bietet im Grunde jeder Player außer Spotify. Vielleicht rüsten sie sowas noch nach. Aber es ist schon erstaunlich, inwieweit. Klar, die haben das Interesse, dass relativ viele gute Inhalte bei Spotify direkt abrufbar sind, dass die Leute die Plattform nicht verlassen. Aber dass sie dann doch den Raum geben und das Mitglieder verwaltungsmäßige einfach bei Steady belassen. Das ist schon eine ganz gute Arbeitsteilung, von der wir, glaube ich, dann auch gut profitieren können.
Jetzt nochmal die Nachfrage. Das heißt, wenn man noch nicht bei Steady angemeldet ist, dann kann man aber trotzdem bei Spotify auf diesen Button klicken. Und dann wird man entsprechend weitergeleitet, dass man sich dann anmelden kann. Genau, da wird man durchgeleitet.
Entweder man ist in seinem Browser oder wo auch immer schon bei Steady angemeldet, dann wird das einfach durchgereicht, die Anmeldung. Dann weiß Spotify Bescheid. Solange man bei Steady aktiver Kunde ist, ist es dann auch bei Spotify einfach freigeschaltet. Also in deren Sicht, ich könnte es mir jetzt nicht einfacher vorstellen. Es ist einfach gut, wie sie es gemacht haben. Und in deren Sicht nutzen wir das natürlich dann auch.
Prima, viele Wege führen jetzt. Ja, viele Wege führen jetzt in den Salon. Und dann sehen wir uns dort gleich. Yes, haut rein, bis gleich.
Bis gleich.